[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Freitagabend was im Sport passiert ist
erfahren sie von Norbert Lehmann einen
schönen guten Tag wie können die
Menschen entlastet werden bei den hohen
Energiepreisen eines unserer Themen
heute
teure energiepreisbremse der Bundestag
beschließt das 200 Milliarden Euro teure
Hilfspaket Gas und Stromrechnungen
sollen so bezahlbar bleiben
wer wird neuer premier in Großbritannien
bringen sich die Kandidaten für die
Nachfolge von List Trust ins Stellung
ein Comeback von Boris Johnson scheint
möglich
und verheerende Überschwemmungen große
Teile Nigerias stehen unter Wasser mehr
als 600 Menschen sind bereits ums Leben
gekommen
[Musik]
die 200 Milliarden Euro zur Bewältigung
der Energiekrise stehen der Bundestag
hat heute grünes Licht gegeben aber wie
ganz genau die Hilfen aussehen sollen
ist noch unklar und der Druck auf die
Regierung steigt die gaspreisbremse
nicht erst ab März sondern bereits ab
Januar einzuführen Ines Trumps berichtet
mit den Stimmen der Ampel gegen die
Opposition verabschiedet der Bundestag
den 200 Milliarden starken Abwehrschirm
eine Gas- und strompreisbremse soll er
finanzieren auch wackelnde Unternehmen
Stützen zuvor ein Schlagabtausch denn
unklar ist wie genau Bürger und
Unternehmen entlastet werden sollen die
Opposition spricht von Blankoscheck
heute steht einfach zur Entscheidung
dass Sie von uns ein Geldsack haben
wollen gefüllt mit 200 Milliarden Euro
und den wollen sie sich dann in den
Keller ihrer Regierung stellen und dann
wollen sie überlegen und dann wollen sie
überlegen was sie mit dem Geld anfangen
es geht um etwas was für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und für die Unternehmen
wichtig ist nämlich die Einhaltung des
Versprechens dass die Ampelkoalition
noch vor dem Winter dafür sorgt dass
ausreichende Finanzmittel für
Unternehmen und Bürger vorhanden sein
werden auch die Finanzierung ist
umstritten Kredite im Rahmen eines
Sonderfonds am Bundeshaushalt vorbei
zeitgleich in Hannover die
Ministerpräsidenten Tagen mit dem
Finanz- und dem Wirtschaftsminister die
Länderchefs kritisieren den Zeitplan der
Entlastungen dass der Dezember Abschlag
erstattet werden die Gaspreis Bremse
aber erst im März greifen soll sie muss
früher kommen eine Wirksamkeit ab 1
Januar wäre deutlich besser als eine
Wirksamkeit ab März wir können der
Bundesregierung nur dringend abraten bei
der gaspreisbremse den vorgeschlagenen
Ablauf der Expertenkommission sich zu
eigen zu machen im Bundestag
signalisiert die SPD heute
Entgegenkommen auf diesen Kritikpunkt
die Hilfen könnten eventuell früher
kommen
insofern werden wir auch darüber reden
ob es zum Beispiel eine Rückwirkung
geben kann einer oder ob es noch eine
weitere Abschlagszahlung geben kann nach
Bundestag und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist nun die
Regierung am Zug sie muss festsorin wie
die Energiepreise konkret gedeckelt
werden sollen
schauen wir wie das alles bei den
Menschen ankommt und dazu ist Matthias
vorne vom Studio mit dem ZDF
Politbarometer guten Abend Matthias was
sagen denn die Befragten tut die
Regierung genug um die hohen Preise
abzufedern die Menschen spüren natürlich
schon die erhöhten Preise nicht aber die
versprochene Entlastung und deshalb
findet eine Mehrheit dass die
Bundesregierung dann noch zu wenig tut
55 Prozent vor allem die Anhänger von
AFD und Linke sehen das ganz überwiegend
so und wie sehen die Befragten ihre
eigene wirtschaftliche Situation
54 Prozent beurteilen ihre Lager als gut
die Erwartungen fürs nächste Jahr aber
ist eher pessimistisch 43 Prozent
rechnen damit dass sie ihre eigene
wirtschaftliche Lage verschlechtern wird
und was bedeutet das für die Parteien
wie werden sie beurteilt wir schauen uns
mal die Bewertung der ampelpartei an die
SPD macht ihre Sache eher gut sagen 52
Prozent die Grünen mit 49% guter
Bewertung die FDP dagegen macht ihre
Arbeit sehr schlecht findet eine
Mehrheit von 53 Prozent
wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme
die SPD auf 19 Prozent plus eins im
Vergleich zur letzten Umfrage vor drei
Wochen
cdu/csu 28 Prozent ebenfalls plus eins
grüne 21 - 1
fdp6-1 AFD 15 plus 1 und die Linke
unverändert bei 5%
. damit hätte die Ampel erstmals seit
der letzten Bundestagswahl keine
Mehrheit mehr reichen würde es aber für
Schwarz-Grün Dankeschön Matthias
und das gesamte Politbarometer können
Sie um 22 Uhr heute journal sehen und
natürlich jederzeit online
damit Deutschland gut durch den Winter
kommt soll ja jeder und jede Gas sparen
angesichts der hohen Preise schont das
auch das Portemonnaie und es ist gut
fürs Klima wie viel Gas wurde in
Deutschland bereits eingespart und wie
weit sind die Gasspeicher gefüllt
Alexandra war Carlo über den aktuellen
Stand
das hat sich schon mal gelohnt
niedrigere Temperaturen in den Büros das
runterdrehen zu Hause und statt baden
besser Duschen 31 Prozent haben die
Deutschen in der letzten Woche an Gas
gespart im Vergleich zu den
Oktoberwochen der letzten Jahre auch
wegen des außergewöhnlich warmen
herbstmonats und so sind die Gasspeicher
voll stand heute
96,52 Prozent mehr als im speichergesetz
vorgesehen die gaslage in Deutschland
also stabil sagt die Bundesnetzagentur
als oberster Wächter über das Gasnetz
und weil Deutschland ordentlich Gas
einkauft wie in Norwegen oder den
Niederlanden könnte das Gas bis zum
Frühjahr reichen allerdings bei einem
besonders kalten Winter könnten die
Speicher schonende Februar annähernd
leer sein die Gefahr einer gasmangellage
ist also gegeben deshalb heißt es weiter
den Gasverbrauch senken das Ziel 20%
weniger als im Vorjahr so die
Bundesnetzagentur die EU-Länder haben
bereits be ihren Gasverbrauch um 15% zu
senken
und die EU will jetzt auch gemeinsam Gas
einkaufen damit es günstiger wird darauf
haben sich die Staats- und
regierungschefinnen und Chefs bei ihrem
Gipfel geeinigt gestritten wurde dagegen
bis tief in die Nacht über ein
europäischen gaspreisdeckel Deutschland
lädt ihn ab am Ende ein
Minimalkompromiss aus Busse Julia rech
und Ulf
halb 3 Uhr nachts Europa schlief bereits
als ein Mann die Bühne suchte Scholz der
Neinsager hieß es auf dem Gipfel mit
müdem Blick versucht er diesem Eindruck
entgegen zu wirken einen schönen guten
Morgen
wir haben uns zusammengerauft und so
sieht zusammengerauft aus die
deutsch-französische Achse kriselt vor
den aufgereihten Kameras kein Versuch
harmonische Bilder zu inszenieren
sondern eine geschäftsmäßige Begrüßung
heute morgen deutschland lehnt weiter
den gaspreisdeckel ab macron und viele
andere wollen ihn der Kompromiss ein
Prüfauftrag an die Fachminister nächste
Woche den macron selbstbewusst verkauft
die Tatsache dass wir unsere
Entschlossenheit zeigen mit diesem
Instrument voranzugehen das ist ein
klares Signal an die Märkte wir handeln
entschieden und geeint es ist Krieg in
Europa und die Regierungschefs wollen
der Welt und den Finanzmärkten mehr als
Vertagung von Lösungen anbieten zum
Beispiel die EU will gemeinsam Gas
einkaufen um bessere Preise zu bekommen
der Kanzler ist auch dafür
beim gemeinsamen Einkauf von Gast sind
wir ebenfalls weitergekommen private
Unternehmen können sich auf freiwilliger
Basis für Einkäufe zusammenschließen
dass ein großer Fortschritt weil bisher
das Wettbewerbsrecht gegen solche
Aktivitäten steht und wenn das geändert
wird dann ist das an Fortschritt Olaf
Scholz und Emanuel macron haben diesen
Gipfel mit ihrem Streit geprägt die
Missstimmung im deutsch-französischen
Verhältnis belastende EU und erschweren
Kompromisse zu finden und das in einer
Zeit in der Europa stark und geschlossen
sein müsste der EU-Gipfel ist sich in
vielen Detailfragen noch uneinig aber
wenigstens einig sich nicht mehr so laut
zu streiten
ein Thema am Rande des EU-Gipfels war
auch der geplante Teilverkauf eines
Hamburger Hafenterminals an China
mehrere Länder warnten Bundeskanzler
Scholz vor dem Einstieg des chinesischen
Staatsunternehmens auch die
EU-Kommission ist nach Medienberichten
dagegen Scholz wie ist die Kritik zurück
in der Sache sei noch nichts entschieden
viele Fragen seien noch zu klären auch
die Koalitionspartner grün und FDP
kritisieren das Vorhaben
Italien bekommt wohl zum ersten Mal eine
Frau in der Spitze der Regierung die
Chefin der rechtsradikalen Partei Brüder
Italiens Georgia melloni wird neue
Ministerpräsidentin Staatschef
mattarella erteilte ihr am frühen Abend
den Auftrag zur Regierungsbildung morgen
soll das neue Kabinett dann vereidigt
werden die drei rechten Parteien hatten
bei der Wahl Ende September eine
deutliche Mehrheit erzielt
und auch in Großbritannien ist gerade
die entscheidende Frage wer wird neue
Regierungschef oder Chefin nach dem
Rücktritt von List Trust ist plötzlich
sogar eine Rückkehr von Boris Johnson
möglich wir erinnern uns er musste nach
zahlreichen Skandalen schließlich Anfang
September wegen einer partygate-affäre
sein Hut nehmen bis Ende nächster Woche
wollen die Tories einen neuen Premier
bestimmt haben Neuwahlen wollen sie auf
jeden Fall vermeiden weil sie so
schlecht in den Umfragen da stehen
Andreas Stamm
kandidatenjagd in London wäre wirft
seinen Hut in den Ring die Kontrahenten
bleiben heute unverbindlich auch
Ex-Finanzminister Richie sunack Favorit
der konservativen Parlamentsfraktion
doch in aller Munde ist sein ehemaliger
Boss expremier Johnson
astalavista Baby mit einem astalavista
Wiedersehen hatte er sich Anfang Juli
nach seinem Rauswurf verabschiedet nun
wächst der Kreis derer die seinen
Comeback wollen darunter einflussreiche
Partei Schwergewichte mit wem gewinnen
wir die nächste Wahl für jede Partei
gerade jetzt natürlich äußerst wichtig
momentan tendiere ich zu Boris ein
Retter an der Wahlurne verführerisch für
eine Partei deren Abgeordnete
scharenweise um ihren Job bangen doch
ist das Chaos sind die Skandale und
Fehltritte der Ära Johnson schon
vergessen
die Aussicht dass jemand wie er als
Premier zurückkehren könnte ist
erbärmlich ein prinzipienloser
lügnerischer Possenreißer
gut gemacht
meine Meinung ganz ehrlich ich will
Boris wieder
der große Vorteil Boris Johnsons die
beiden Kandidaten die am Montag die
meisten Stimmen der Fraktion bekommen
gehen in eine Stichwahl entschieden von
rund 170.000 Parteimitgliedern einem
mini-bruchteil der Bevölkerung und deren
Favorit könnte der Ex-Premier sein von
der wirtschaftszerstörerin Liz Trust
zurück zu einem Mann den seine eigene
Partei für amtsunfähig erklärt hat
nichts könnte mehr für Neuwahlen
sprechen
die wollen auch Johnsons
innerparteiliche Gegner anstreben für
den Fall seines Comebacks zurzeit noch
im Karibikurlaub kommt er zurück erstmal
nach London kehrte an die Spitze zurück
könnte auf die Briten noch mehr
politisches Chaos warten
vier Monate Haft wegen Missachtung des
US-Kongresses das ist das Urteil gegen
den ehemaligen Trump vertrauten Steve
bennen der ex-berater des früheren
Präsidenten hatte sich geweigert unter
Eid vor einem parlamentarischen
Ausschuss zur kapitolerstimmung
auszusagen außerdem lehnt er es ab
angeforderte Dokumente auszuhändigen
wir schauen in die Ukraine Russland hat
dort bereits große Teile des
Energieversorgungsnetzes zerstört und
nun wirft Präsident selenski Moskau vor
einen staudampf
vor einer Katastrophe großen Ausmaßes
falls der Damm des
wasserkraftwerkskajofaka im Süden des
Landes bricht unter anderem könnte dann
die umkämpfte Stadt herson überflutet
werden Moskau wie ist die Vorwürfe
zurück
die jüngsten Angriffe haben gezeigt
russland versucht die Ukraine jetzt auf
breiter Front unter Druck zu setzen
in Moskau Strategie spielt dabei der
Enge Verbündete Belarus eine wichtige
Rolle mehr als 1.000 Kilometer lang ist
die Grenze zur Ukraine zu Beginn des
Krieges marschierten russische Truppen
von hier aus Richtung Kiew jetzt schickt
Russland wieder tausende Soldaten samt
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen nach Belarus ein
Ablenkungsmanöver oder ernsthafte
Bedrohung Nina nebergall
seit Tagen veröffentlicht das
belarussische Verteidigungsministerium
diese Bilder russische Soldaten die in
Belarus ankommen sie schüren die Sorge
dass eine gemeinsame Truppe von hier die
Ukraine angreift und genau das sollen
sie wohl auch
ich habe vor zwei Jahren schon gesagt
die Zeit wird kommen wenn Putin und ich
Rücken an Rücken stehen werden und
zurückschießen
9000 russische Soldaten sollen
belarussische bei der Verteidigung der
Grenze zur Ukraine unterstützen so heißt
es offiziell ganz im Gleichklang mit
Putins Propaganda
seit den Protesten vor zwei Jahren steht
Lukaschenko unter Druck
Regimekritiker wie Igor Elias glauben
einen Einmarsch in die Ukraine kann sich
der Diktator nicht leisten
es gibt in der Gesellschaft einen
gewissen
antikriegskonsens auf einer Armee in so
einer Atmosphäre agiert kann man sich
nicht verlassen berücksichtigt man dann
noch die beispiellosen Proteste vor zwei
Jahren sowie das Lukaschenko keine
Unterstützung mehr am Volk hat ist das
eine ziemlich explosive Mischung die
kann zu Aufständen oder einer Revolution
führen
unabhängige Experten gehen ohnehin davon
aus dass sich an der Grenze keine
schlagfertige Truppe formiert vielmehr
seines frisch eingezogene russische
Reservisten die erstmal in Belarus
ausgebildet werden
wenn es bei dieser Gruppe von neun oder
zehntausend Russen bleibt dann geht es
wahrscheinlich nur darum eine Bedrohung
im Norden zu schaffen damit die Ukraine
ihre Armee von dort nicht abziehen kann
noch ist es eine russisch belarussische
druckkulisse aufgebaut von zwei Männern
unter Druck doch genau das macht es so
gefährlich und unberechenbar
und wir schauen auf unseren
Nachbarkontinent Afrika während dort
viele Regionen seit Jahren unter Dürre
leiden kämpfen andere Gebiete mit
massiven Überschwemmungen in Westafrika
ist zurzeit Nigeria besonders betroffen
und dort die Region südlich der
Hauptstadt Abuja das Hochwasser der
großen Flüsse Niger und benui hat bisher
etwa 600 Menschenleben gefordert Sandra
Theis berichtet
Luftaufnahmen aus koginigeria von vor
ein paar Tagen der Niger und sein
Zufluss haben weite Teile des Landes
überschwemmt rund 1,3 Millionen Menschen
haben laut Behörden ihr Zuhause verloren
mit dem wenigen Hab und Gut dass sie
tragen können fliehen sie aus den
Überschwemmungsgebieten
in diesem Auffanglager in Port Harkort
haben etwa 2000 Menschen Zuflucht
gesucht die Verzweiflung ist groß
ich habe meine Farm verloren mein Laden
ich habe alles verloren genau genommen
habe ich gar nichts mehr
es gibt kaum essen kein sauberes Wasser
keine Toiletten keine Intimsphäre Männer
und Frauen leben in einer Halle
die Angst dass sich
Infektionskrankheiten ausbreiten ist
groß
viele Straßen sind überflutet das Wasser
zerstörte schätzungen zufolge auch
hunderttausende Hektar Agrarland es
droht eine Hungerkrise manche Experten
machen den Klimawandel für die
Flutkatastrophe verantwortlich in
Nigeria ist zwar Regenzeit doch seit
August kam besonders viel herunter
die Menge an Regen und die Frequenzen
der wir heutzutage in ganz Nigeria
Überschwemmungen haben ist definitiv
eine Folge des sich verändernden Klimas
der Klimawandel ist der Schuldige Nummer
eins
es wird befürchtet dass sich die Lage
noch verschlimmert denn in den nächsten
Tagen soll es weiter regnen
noch einmal nach Deutschland fast ein
Jahr ist das her dass ein Mann in einem
ICE mit einem Messer um sich stach heute
hat der Prozess gegen den mutmaßlichen
Täter vor dem Oberlandesgericht München
begonnen die Bundesanwalt schafft wirft
den Beschuldigten unter anderem
versuchten Mord vor die Anklage geht von
einem islamistischen Motiv des heute
28-jährigen aus der in Syrien aufwuchs
im vergangenen November soll er in einem
ICE von Passau nach Nürnberg plötzlich
vier Männer angegriffen und zum Teil
schwer verletzt haben
jetzt kommen wir zum Sport zur
Fußball-Bundesliga 11 Spieltag Norbert
einige Vereine stehen ja nicht dort wo
man sie vor Saison beginnen vermutet hat
natürlich allen voran Tabellenführer
Union Berlin Dortmund dagegen ist so ein
Club der auf Rang 8 deutlich unter den
Erwartungen liegt seit Saisonbeginn ein
Auf und Ab keine konstante Leistung in
der Liga am Samstag geht es daheim gegen
den VfB
nur im Pokal und in der Champions League
stimmt der bvb-kurs Sinnbild der
fehlenden Konstanz Torwart Kobel er ist
mit grobem Patzer in der Liga dann
wieder mit starken Paraden im Pokal
Führungsspieler Hummels kritisiert
öffentlich die Spielweise was auch nicht
zur Beruhigung der Lage beiträgt ein
bisschen mehr darauf angewiesen die
Dinge von innen und nicht nur von extern
beeinflussen zu wollen und da sind wir
alle im gleichen Boot und wir werden
jetzt weiter miteinander sprechen und
hoffe ich weniger übereinander Gegner
Stuttgart kommt mit Rückenwind unter
Interims Coach Michael Wimmer gab es
zuletzt zwei Siege und zehn zu eins gut
möglich dass er bis zur Winterpause
weitermachen darf es gibt eine ganz
klare Absprache dass ich so lange das
Aushilfe bis ein neuer Chef drin ist der
BVB ist gewarnt und muss wohl erneut auf
Kapitän raus verzichten die Lage bleibt
angespannt
das Spitzenspiel der Bundesliga der
Frauen das steigt am Sonntag Wolfsburg
gegen die Bayern über 18.000 Karten hat
der VfL für das Heimspiel schon verkauft
der die Titelverteidigerinnen und
tabellenführerinnen in Topform beflügelt
vom 14.0 Champions League sie gestern
gegen St Pölten aber auch die
Tabellenzweiten aus München mit sehr
gutem Lauf vorgestern der 2:1 Sieg in
der Königsklasse gegen den FC
Rosengarten
ja und eine ganz besondere Ehre für die
Wolfsburgerin Jule Brandt die deutsche
fußballnationalspielerin ist heute als
Golden Girl 2022 zur besten U21
Spielerin Europas gekühlt worden
der deutsche handballmeister SC
Magdeburg hat bei der Club WM in
Saudi-Arabien das Halbfinale erreicht
der Titelverteidiger gewann gestern
gegen den saudischen Vertreter halitsch
mit 35 zu 29 der zweite Sieg im zweiten
Gruppenspiel bester Magdeburger Werfer
Daniel Pettersson und Lukas Mertens mit
jeweils fünf Treffern und am Samstag das
Halbfinale gegen Ägyptens
handballrekordmeister Allach Dankeschön
morgen regnet es im Süden oft ist es
aber auch freundlich Details hat gleich
Christa Orban das heute journal läuft an
diesem Abend um 22 Uhr mit Marietta
Slomka schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht und morgen
verstärkt sich der Regen im Süden noch
mal denn ein Sturmtief über Irland und
den britischen Inseln schickt uns ein
weiteres kleines Randtief so gibt es
schon in der Nacht mit den eingelagerten
Gewittern vor allem im Südschwarzwald
kräftigen Regen der sich im nachtverlauf
nach Osten verschiebt im Nordosten
lassen letzte Schauer und Gewitter nach
es wird trocken örtlich auch neblig in
der feuchten Luft oft bleibt es aber
auch bewölkt und so sinken die
Temperaturen in der Nacht selten in den
einstelligen Bereich meist bleibt es bei
14 bis 10 Grad morgen gibt es verbreitet
sehr milde 18 bis 22 Grad im Südosten da
bleiben wir aber teils bei 15 Grad denn
hier ist es vormittags regnerisch vom
Bodensee bis zum Erzgebirge nachmittags
zieht das Ganze nach Osten ab es
verbleiben letzte Schauer auch im Norden
sind einzelne Schauer unterwegs oft
heitert es nachmittags aber auf am
Sonntag dreht der Wind auf Süd damit
sind im Südwesten bis 23 Grad drin ist
das Trocken abgesehen von einzelnen
schauen nachmittags im Westen mit der
neuen Woche kommt ein neues Tief bringt
stärkeren Wind mit mehr Schauer wieder
eingelagerte Gewitter das lässt am
Dienstag aber nach und auch die neue
Woche startet sehr mild tschüss